[Music]
three two one action hey guys welcome
back to off-the-record where we talk
about whatever we want thank you thank
you
crossbones do you know that one mmm
Isaac learned it I don't know what
followed you around I assume kids
playgrounds mm-hmm the Pied Piper is a
story about a rapist right no he's not a
rapist yeah that's what that's what they
did because I think he would go to the
town and then he plays a little flute
and then I think the mighty like the
mice all the kids came out it wasn't
sexual
but they're saying are Kelly because he
makes music and then all the young girls
come she came out during the [ __ ]
plague dude that's why because he would
kids would so many kids would die or
like disappear and [ __ ] so then around
the room he'll be like he'll be like
[ __ ] it happy childhood remembering from
Germany and then the kids would just
follow him and then they were just all
back he's essentially dead you would
flute that the death what would you
rather do give your you give your kids
like psychological to tell ya if like
you gave them these stories that were
unrealistic and then they're terrified
of some like unrealistic [ __ ] or just
beat their ass I'm talking about a boy
tie [ __ ] round house of the chest
Jesus it's like we're getting a B are
you talking about like are you comparing
so one is like Muay Thai kick them in
the chest beat the [ __ ] out of them
right and the psychological one it's
like now every time they see a
strawberry they [ __ ] themselves in the
crime forget I asked this question you
guys taking [ __ ] fall I want to know
I want to know the severity yeah I don't
know you guys took it to the extreme or
my mind rather kicked my kid in the face
then give them mental exactly mental
trauma it's like so hard in York in the
face gives a little drama
think about it all the time like brain
trauma if you ran into someone on the
street that was four times your height
and ten times your strength you'd be
stressed out and kids deal with that all
the time
well my parents beat the [ __ ] out of me
I live any mental trauma none oh yeah
yeah let's we could we could debate that
huh if we if we got beat up by it like
adults adult yeah cuz we'll be up to
their kneecap but you don't fight back
when you're a kid oh I tried but I
failed to someone who's 20 feet tall
yeah yeah I never got what would be
fighting why would I know I would never
roundhouse my child but I would do
something like that that's why I can see
what Kerry exists yes Mike do man
bullets don't care about the size boom
in your face that's kind of martial art
is run yep
too bad on TV shoot myself before
anything else I'd like gun accessories
alliance they're so [ __ ] cool like
that [ __ ] lookit I've been watching all
these videos where you can just make
guns pop out of nowhere in your [ __ ]
house that [ __ ] where you're in your
[ __ ] [ __ ] then and you hit something
it just Falls that's a lot of John wick
scenarios go and do much I know but I
like because I'm clumsy as [ __ ] so I'm
more scared than to shoot myself the
John wick she is crazy
that's tiny because so what they did was
like the plot of that movie right
because he ends up getting like a suit
that's bulletproof but the suits
comfortable to wear and looks nice yeah
highly pissed yeah well what they did
was is these like at Men's Wearhouse
this movie works better if he's
invincible yeah like give him a suit we
covered that in a minute and a half now
I can't be shot easy dude I just like
all that weird [ __ ] they have that [ __ ]
the [ __ ] fingerprints swiped me we're
just [ __ ] comes down to [ __ ] oh the
one that pulls up like you pull it up if
you had access to get your gun out like
in an emergency situation it was the
same way that you turn on your phone
which works most of the time I don't
trust that yeah really
[ __ ] look bass ready yeah sunglasses on
now
oh [ __ ] that's crazy so the more
technology there is the scarier it is
for you to have that weapon because it
can be less reliable because of the
malfunctioning properties that's are
supposed to train with they're supposed
to train for all the Emergencies
three-syllable and then so your whatever
when something happens it becomes muscle
memory because it would be like a
situation where there's like a robber
and this is the wall and I'm like stupid
ass into doesn't come out like what are
you doing it just comes out it's because
we have fine motor skills that has gross
motor skills and when you're scared it's
difficult to activate those fine motor
skills yeah you'll never be able to do
calligraphy and it's like imagine doing
surgery when you got ten zombies trying
to bite you right like it's not gonna
work
I did them so plucking your eyebrows if
you're like time/space now I've been too
hot over a microwave that's not even an
emergency you just sit there like too
much thinking man damn yeah I cut myself
on a metal grate the other day because I
was so frantic what were you grating no
it was like the baby that goes into a
grill and that medal it's nothing that
sharp I somehow cut my thumb okay I was
bleeding all over the place man that's
just why it was [ __ ] crazy dude like
you know when you look at a cut and it's
like it's not that bad and I started
walking around the house and there's
just trail of blood what my dog has a
period what the [ __ ] is back home with
my parents
he's been saying that for the past five
years for God this fool will be telling
me [ __ ] that I'm there this fool look at
me he goes oh did you know Kalai was an
Olympic swimmer I'm like yeah you [ __ ] I
was there with you dude and you did tell
you your story
he does that she told me not you dude
that was me now you should have put your
hand over your heart and it's like slows
down the waiting I want it like this
vertebra
I felt the other way put it below your
kneecaps it's if you're upset I see that
make sense I just woke up in a [ __ ]
pool of my own blood soak it in milk
dude are you [ __ ] her out no I don't
[ __ ] like you to the Jews if you get
your tooth out you put it in milk and
then take it to a dentist they could
reattach it if it's like Faso doesn't
die I bet Amin no can't do this [ __ ] guy
yeah haven't you seen like a black tooth
fuel with buck teeth I see a lot of good
it means do to the best [ __ ] yeah but
that's cause it Beach nut no the
paint'll not the beta letter it's it
does that bean love it's like that
narcotic almost yeah yeah it's like it's
kind of like cocaine type of I because I
tried it in IE tried it well the tour
guide they give it to you for you it's
like Chinese chewing tobacco
yeah [ __ ] guys your teeth blood tingly
and I didn't like it so I it tastes
terrible by the way I don't like mouth
tobacco so I it so you you try it you
spit it out once and then you chew it
again so I don't know what that guy
Caliburn yeah you spin it like into your
hand and then jam it back in is on the
floor like the Jews you spit the juicer
because that's what I picture
this is gonna go great the second
enzymes on the floor activate you have a
go papi I'm like why would you even I
sand wet and then mix it with carpet
lamp and then it's good to go
it needs a little dust to activate this
this is get you high but it's supposed
to be like an extreme caffeine high but
it made my head tink like a little buzz
or something I've never tired [ __ ]
tingle do that like if I spit that [ __ ]
out like gross I mean didn't that the
same thing with cocaine would they would
do the coca leaves and Alina chew coca
leaves saying the same idea and I sure
would keep them up you don't like but a
lot of the taxi drivers in Taiwan have
that [ __ ] yeah the like the coca leaves
they'll do like for high-altitude stuff
so yeah here because they don't work the
same as like viagra because it lowers
blood pressure there's a vasodilator
but in if it's in small doses like that
it's not as harmful as like when it's
processed cocaine and correct yeah yeah
mmm I want to try it is always
fascinating I'm like this is nothing
like crack homie I worked with a guy one
time that was telling me that he like
used to do a bunch of coke and then he
explains it to him he's like yeah you
know like a the guy would buy it from
you know would mix it with like baking
soda and make these rocks I'm like oh
crap I used to do a bunch of crack
baking soda and it turned into a rock
right like listen listen he mixes into a
stone and then I light it smoke it do
they do that so I could distribute the
cocaine more yes / yeah I mean it's
easier to smoke it's easier to do ya
[ __ ] you up real hard yeah smokeable
form yeah I mean look people aren't
addicted to crack cuz it makes you feel
bad mm-hmm that's true like all drugs
that's a [ __ ] philosopher right there
that's [ __ ] dope man is that like
something that's so [ __ ] good like
anything else that you've been into in
your entire life you're like this is
better yeah
a little odd right because you have to
develop something an attachment or a
chemical smokings a little different
because it's yeah you gotta force
yourself to get poisoned because it's
the nicotine basically poisons your body
and as its releasing it's like when you
get a heart massage right it's it's
painful but then when they're done and
release it you go ah like you relax
you're back to your [ __ ] chest you're
so skinny
maybe built like a memory foam mattress
just [ __ ] handprints left and they
liked if gets bruises we're just walking
there's a bruise on the bottom ER oh my
god after working out with Cassie shut
up I swear to you till this day my quads
feel so like Pilates our Sunday no
Saturday you got sore from Pilates yes
it's a deal it's don't look first the
first move she doesn't move that's
longer but she how does do this right
like squats and then she had its go like
this pulse pulse pulse for like forever
and that's [ __ ] me up are you in bed
all day most of the day do you have like
an adjustable bed too you gotta move
your body girl no no I'm better do
grandma exercises enemies nail
technician says you get called as a bad
circulation shouldn't tell you but she
told the nice but I have been trying to
be better but I've never been that sort
like that this soreness it almost feels
like I got punched in my you got rhabdo
like when it comes to a [ __ ] Fitness
George st. Pierre straighter Feroz frost
is a hobby yeah like he's specifically a
man I like it because he makes me feel
good about myself
nice he goes don't ever work out till
your sword that's my philosophy
talking about pro athletes to have a
certain fitness level exactly to be sore
but are you talking abut but like you
need to get sort of build up there
what's going on here I mean if you get
sore from walking around that's pretty
bad oh oh
basketball courts out in South Pasadena
I compete all the time I'd beat a 13
year old yesterday I [ __ ]
Mokey's asked you that's don't cross him
up you're you're all then okay knock his
teeth out dude
and his dad whooped my ass but it's all
good yeah but I like this a training
method though it's about is it about
frequency versus going only Hamblin so
yeah yeah who only goes ham once a week
whose training philosophy is that it was
like because I would always think that I
was like once a year yeah work out with
that stuff I'll never do that again you
go so hard day 19 done you know that
[ __ ] first time you're in the gym
you're like I know what my goals are and
then you go so [ __ ] ham and then you
explode your all your muscles I'm just
in bed for like two three weeks so I
just that's what I would do every
[ __ ] year
cuz the year would come by I see the gym
ads and I go you know what now's the
time
Davis sells a new man you're trying to
burn like ten years worth of weight just
they need one day we're gonna do this
once every three weeks cuz I always see
him or he who works out like he hates
himself I love my son and or to probably
why why not well look at you you make
him look like he's your little brother
or some [ __ ]
like when you're not here he looks like
the epitome of fitness and then when you
walked in the door he look like a piece
of [ __ ] me it looks like from this to
this is that I look like [ __ ] before
picture no you look [ __ ] mad like
that shirt all the seams are coming off
that's how it's you're supposed to fit
he's trying to make muscles [ __ ]
crazy with you learning anywhere it's
ever come from everybody that we hang
out with they don't really work out to
the extent that he does right so when
you walk into the barbell and you see
him stand next to another guy it's like
oh there's people bigger than him plenty
cuz you know we worked at 24 and there's
only a few people at 24 yeah actually
I've got a membership doing those and
it's really hard for me to go there
there's a lot of [ __ ] I just cancel
my membership one of the few people that
I know that's under 200 pounds are you
under 200 pounds yeah
leave it alone
that's your mail I know well you should
have saw Bart Kwan at 240 pounds that
[ __ ] was disgusting the man I love
that's a peacock the peak of our
friendship peak performance is what that
was I used to be 290 240 now like you
city [ __ ] 240 bro you stand like it's
little
it's all relative though right you
probably yeah I've got a friend that's
[ __ ] 438 house Hall is the court next
in what does he do for a living as a
t-mobile [ __ ] operator digs up
straw picks up heavy things okay that's
awesome that it makes sense then I
thought he was like 430 pounds
oh no it's really weird to me the idea
of like you're 10 inches taller than me
and 200 pounds heavier and like to stand
on a scale and see four is the first
number and be like sweet and it's not an
animal as a human being that's for
Tiff's stacked upon each other yeah this
is how fear even fit on the scale or as
toes like color I'm sure he has to get a
block or something get into some like
harness and they just weigh him from a
crane he has to go to those recycling
centers and instead on that scale it
tranquilize him like a tiger or like a
bear I just you know on each foot like
fitness [ __ ] I always see the power
lifters that go up and then they have
their friend beat the [ __ ] on the back
of their head no one that they slap them
in the face yeah and he knocks out like
I see what Ronnie Scott Mendelson them
up I ever seen I wasn't ever [ __ ]
into that yeah I'd like [ __ ] often at
you at one doing man no they hit them
full force with their hands you know if
I got it I'll just go back
boom boom people like that stuff you
like it it psyched out like that oh he's
like I just went for the ammonia stuff
what is that dude does that wake you up
like what for sure so like you there's
definitely like a big chemical dump and
like other than the sciency side of it
what I got out of it was that like
whenever I hit it what is it smelling
salts like ammonia salt knowing people
faint
basically you sniff one of those before
you lift and so you get this big
adrenaline spike from it and then like
the the response your body gets at least
for me was that like nothing else
[ __ ] matters brain completely [ __ ]
goes clean I know what's [ __ ] healthy
though I mean working out at the way
I've had for the last 20 years I would
call healthy well I'm laying in bed all
days and he'll be either so you might as
well sniff that shouldn't go have both
of them are pretty wrong you know what I
did here though PCC aka angel dust is a
very strong drug because when you take
that [ __ ] you gonna kick out police door
like car doors and you could jump off a
building's and still stay alive I don't
makes your bones stronger though nah
it's just when you're probably dying but
you know every bone is broken I was in
in school there was we were on the roof
watching like Blue Angels and then there
was this girl who's sitting on the edge
and she fell off and she like fell like
ten stories I looked over and like her
body's like she was like Amadou I'm just
like I she looked at like completely I
didn't motionless she was on PCP no
voices like plastered drunk she's
survived by Lisbon her body was just
like yeah like she didn't she didn't try
it I like great for fall break her fall
that's what you're gonna get in a car
wreck yeah it was crazy
either be asleep or be drunk it was
crazy
these are those around looking crackhead
dude she probably got to start doing
karate and [ __ ] she was bones are
brothers right
she's yeah at school drunk that's cool
it's wireless no like there's jets
fighter jets oh it's like a fighter jet
show them so when she was just drinking
Jews like what exactly exactly I
survived it amazingly the [ __ ] that
people survived and then other [ __ ] that
people died right that's why I'm saying
it but your time to go it's your [ __ ]
time there's people that like trip on a
great and like million-dollar baby
themselves on the [ __ ] sidewalk and
they're dead that's true
like tripping their own house I'm like a
wet rag and die meanwhile this chick
falls off a hundred [ __ ] foot
building she's challenged good go yeah
weird day all the things huh cover oh I
thought in your story she got right back
up it's not a dancing it [ __ ] she just
ran it away like terminated she's like
I've never seen something about her
[ __ ] arm just whips back in this knife
hands and runs off there's some crazy
[ __ ] I took I can a story Jay King is a
long time ago what you didn't hear it
but in high school there was a dude that
[ __ ] flew through a [ __ ] car
window
it was his big [ __ ] Samoan [ __ ] in
our school flew through the car window
there's like Nissan Sentra tumbled got
back up and went to the car to help
everybody else it out of the window just
hit the frame who the [ __ ] are you guys
anybody my [ __ ] high school pop flew
up double oh [ __ ] running over to the
[ __ ] guard was it the rock no it was
just this big [ __ ] dude he flew the
[ __ ] out and asked anybody my [ __ ]
high school cuz we were why believe you
we believe
there's almost like unbelievably the
[ __ ] out would you think the reality of
this story is versat true that but he
just he was [ __ ] on the handlebars of
a bike and the guy like hit something
and he shot off it was this old so there
was this dude in our high school
so number it was that same guy that did
that hood surfing thing and the other do
flew off China yes so he has a history
of [ __ ] up with car so this two flew
out the [ __ ] window we're all tumbled
and help the other two out of the car so
more like someone who line people are
made of some different [ __ ] dude
yeah coconut skin
[Music]